for more let's dig a little bit deeper
with chief election and campaign
correspondent robert costa uh bob good
morning to you we just heard the uh
tweet from or not the tweet the truth
social from the former president this
morning uh we also know that he could
have he was at his own liberty to
release the search warrant itself and
the underlying
itemized list but let's go to the news
we learned from merrick garland
yesterday that not only did a federal
judge of course sign off on this search
warrant but that garland himself
authorized the request of that warrant
how significant is that
good morning tony it's highly
significant for this former judge
merrick garland who almost landed on the
supreme court to speak out he normally
does not speak out but he saw the
institutional integrity of the justice
department being questioned he wanted to
offer clarity to a point knowing that
this is an ongoing investigation and
that this is a tumultuous political time
he tried to calm the political waters
but certainly political war continues
with that statement and republican
statements
you know bob as tony just pointed out mr
trump could have released that search
warrant ahead of time he did not now he
says okay guys go ahead what if anything
does that tell you that now he's saying
now now that he's been challenged he's
saying all right release it what is it
it's partly an understandable decision
gail because the
the search warrant itself we're told is
likely a bare bones document pretty
basic in its outline what really matters
in terms of foundational evidence is the
affidavit that led to the search warrant
it's evident that that affidavit is not
going to come out at this time so the
justice department enabled the former
president his legal team to contest the
release of the search warrant in court
and it appears they will not do so so
we'll learn a little bit more perhaps in
the coming days about the details of the
search but not everything that led to it
bob what about the details of the
documents that the fbi is looking for
what more do we know about them
we know that there has been a lot of
concern in the justice department as
this investigation has gone on about
classified materials at the mar-a-lago
state sensitive materials the washington
post reporting about nuclear documents
of some sort being part of that we've
confirmed that nuclear documents were
perhaps part of what the justice
department and fbi agents were looking
for but still a lot of questions to be
answered about what exactly the former
president brought back to florida
all right bob costa for us bob thank you
very much thank you